je peux prendre un selfie oui bien sûr
non juste
avec j'ai besoin de balaner signalement
un homme blan do pas
quitérop je
pas de pas voyager du tout vre chat va
bien
W ma sœur comment tu es grosse je suis
quoi tu es grosse attends attends
attends en fait jeis pas grosse en fait
ça ça s'appelle pulpeuse en fait ça
s'appelle être totalement dans son temps
ça s'appelle être bonne en
fait faut faire vite avant que le
policier nous rattrape allez dépêche-toi
si tu veux pasre son déjeuner attends il
y a un truc bizarre il y a quoi je te
connais tu m'as fait aucun compliment
hein mes moustaches ma cuiniière mon
boule ça t'éblouie pas
n avec
Griff ça va
mais lui c'est pas un gentil faut qu'on
taille allez saute c'est trop haut les
vra chat çaombe toujours sur ses PES ah
pas un vrai chat
aïe